في تونس اعلنا الحزب الجمهوري توقيف ثلاثه
من اعضائه جاء ذلك بعد تصريحات لمحامي
الدفاع عن الوزير السابق الازهر العكرمي
تقول ان قاضي التحقيق امر بايداع موكلهم
في السجن واعتقل العكرمين فيما بدا يعرف
بملف التامر على امن الدوله وفقا للحكومه
التونسيه من جهه اقاله المحاميه ايناس
حراث ان النيابه العامه قررت استمرار
توقيف عضو البرلمان المنحل القيادي في
حركه النهضه سيد الفرجاني على ذمه التحقيق
فيما عرف بقضيه
الانستالينجو يذكر ان هذه القضيه اثرتها
النيابه العامه ضد شركه علاقات عامه
بالدعايه لحركه النهضه وتبييض الاموال
في الاثناء قال الاتحاد الاوروبي انه
يتابع التطورات في تونس بقلق بالغ مشيرا
الى انها تمر بتعقيدات عديده واضاف
الاتحاد في بيان انه يامل ان تستطيع
السلطات ايجاد حلول لتحديات التي تواجهها
البلاد واشار الاتحاد الاوروبي الى ان ملف
تونس سيناقش في الاجتماع المقبل لوزراء
الخارجيه في بروكسل في مارس القادم